[Musik]
mitgefühl
med
[Musik]
hallo hatte blue wings ellis wertpapiere
der ramadan angefangen also der
fastenmonat und ich habe heute ein
richtig tolles bisher für euch was ihr
abends zum fastenbrechen oder eben nach
dem fastenbrechen essen können und zwar
ist das ein schokokuchen und auf
türkisch heißt der abm kaster also
wortwörtlich übersetzt der weinende
kuchen backe ich wahrscheinlich warum
weinst dieser kuchen aber ich denke der
kuchen heißt so weil er mit einer
leckeren schokosoße über wochen wird und
die kleine mädchen die das berühmte
tropfen zählt eben aus wie tränen
ich würde erwarten man muss meinen weil
da suchen einfach zum lecker schmeckt
dadurch mal wieder aufgebaut ist also
hat einen ganz normalen schoko zeigt im
inneren habe keine prüfungspflicht und
zwar jetzt auch typisch mohammed und
obendrüber die schokosoße normalerweise
backt man das ganze so dass man eine
schicht schock und hat darüber demo
halle wer also die putting schicht und
dann geschockt los ist ich habe mir
jetzt aber gedacht ich mache was
besonderes drauf und nehme meine
überraschungs backform die kennt ihr
auch schon in runde habe ich auch in
etwa ein bis zwei teil erst einmal ein
normales backblech mit welchem motor und
1 x 1 praktisch mit wellenmuster und mit
diesem vertiefungen und diese
vertiefungen eignet sich hervorragend
zum befüllen und da habe ich eben auch
diese modelle befüllung mit dabei falls
diese backform nicht habt ist es gar
nicht schlimm dann backen kuchen einfach
in einem ganz normalen backblech oder
zum beispiel in einem eckigen back
rahmen
ich bin sogar fest weil wenn man den
kuchen angab ist dann hat man im inneren
eines viel verschickt und es sieht echt
super hübsch aus vor allem mit erdbeeren
passt wirklich hervorragend in die
saison und ich würde sagen wir starten
jetzt direkt einmal mit dem schoko teig
und ich die zutaten für den kuchenteig
brauche ich für eine prise salz etwas
bunny lake fragt 200 gramm zucker
jeweils 200 milliliter milch oder butter
mädels hier habe ich noch 200 milliliter
öl ein päckchen backpulver 50 gramm
kakaopulver und 250 gramm mehl
ich nehme zuerst einmal die eier wie bei
einem grün zeigt und geht in eine große
schüssel das ganze könnt ihr jetzt mit
dem handrührgerät oder auch mit der
küchenmaschine zu bereiten
da kommt vanille extrakt mit rein eine
prise salz und zucker und die mischung
mit dampf für etwa 45 minuten kriegen
verwirrt wenn die eier mache dann schön
cremig ist so wie hier kommen jetzt die
flüssigkeiten mit abflug ihr könnt jetzt
normale mails verwenden und so ist
natürlich auch im original türkischen
oder z ich nehme ganz gerne buttermilch
in meinen rohöl zeigen weil dann der
zeigt einfach dass ein saftiger wird und
dadurch erspare ich mir später zum
beispiel das überlesen des kuchens mit
mädels denn das macht man in türkischen
städten oft so einfach mit der kuchen
noch mal lustiger wird und wo habe ich
eben den schönen sachgerecht
als nächstes kann ich jetzt wie
trockenen zutaten dazugeben also mehr
kakao und backpulver die werden jetzt
auch kurz eingerührt
den teig für mich ist meine bank vom 1
die habe ich bereits gerettet und auch
e-mails damit der kuchen später einfach
wieder ganz leicht rauskommt ich habe
jetzt hier die einfache menge zubereitet
um die gleiche menge werde ich nochmal
zu bereiten um dann das zweite blech zu
backen
so kommt das heil gibt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 160 grad ober
unterhitze für etwas 20 bis 25 minuten
beide kuchen zeigen dürfen nach dem
backen etwas zehn minuten abkühlen
das ist auch ganz wichtig und vor allem
doch sehr wichtig dass die backzeit von
25 minuten eingehalten wird
denn ansonsten ist der kuchen zeit noch
ein bisschen zu früh jetzt schon raus
stürzten damit jetzt der kuchen aber
nicht an den tag legt könnte jetzt zum
beispiel zucker drüberstreuen damit das
ganze aber nicht so süß nehme ich
einfach ein bisschen becker stärke
vielleicht aber wie gesagt super können
sie aufnehmen dann einfach ein
geschirrtuch drauf und ein abkühlen
gekauft und jetzt den kuchen raus
stützen
am besten ganz kurz auf einer
arbeitsplatte gehen nicht auf dem herz
[Musik]
das ist auch ein bisschen geklebt aber
das ist gar nicht schlimm
den tag werde ich es abdecken und dann
einfach ruhen lassen mit dieser komplett
abgekühlt ist und während der kuren
abkühlt kann ich schon mal die füllung
zubereiten und zwar kommt da eine art
pudding rheine ein vanillepudding auf
türkisch das ganze buch liebe und die
milch wird einfach gebunden mit etwas
stärke und auf raichs ganz typisch für
die türkische küche ist und ihr vorne
zeigen sich mal die zutaten für das
mohammed braucht es 800 milliliter milch
50 gramm zucker 60 gramm steigert das
ist es meist stärker einen etwas reis
stärke und etwas sonne extrakt jetzt
nehme ich die milz und dexter teil der
mir nicht in einen topf und dann kann
ich dem herd auch schon mal anstellen
damit die kaufkraft auf jeden fall
aufpassen dass du nicht überkocht und
einen teil der milch verrührt mir das
stärke das heißt ja jetzt hier die mais
stärke und stark kommt noch die reize
stärker dazu die es wirklich ganz
typisch für die türkische küche
da kommt die restliche milch betreiben
da kann ich das schon mal glatt rühren
förmlich im topf gebe ich jetzt noch den
zucker mit rein und auch mandel extrakt
und da könnt ihr auch gerne ein bis zwei
teelöffel nehmen
das ganze soll wirklich intensiv nach
manila schmecken
und sobald die menschen nehme ich sofort
vom herd herunter damit sie nicht
überkocht ruhig hier die stärke mischung
1 und dann kommt der tops gleich wieder
auf den herbst drauf und lass die
mischung dann nur noch kurz aufkochen
jetzt erkennt ihr vielleicht schon was
die konsistenz auch ein bisschen anders
ist und vor allem richtig mohamad ist
lecker sein bitte nach milchreis kommt
wahrscheinlich durch die eisfläche wird
auch super schnell fest
damit schneller abkühlt würde ich die
skizzierung und damit sich kein
hautoberfläche bild ist ganz jetzt mit
fischer alufolie abdecken und dann
abkühlen lassen
eine kuren helfen sind jetzt abgetönt
und der pudding besten lauwarm
aber es ist auch völlig okay so nämlich
die folie weg und kann das ganze jetzt
mit dem schneebesen noch ein bisschen
glatt rühren
und wer keine moral liebe füllung machen
möchte kann zum beispiel auch eine fahne
kleben reinfeldt dann ist natürlich
nicht mehr natürlich aber schmeckt
natürlich auch sehr gut und vor allem
ausgeschüttet die mast natürlich jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel da habe ich ein
loch töne vorne drin
ihr könnt noch mit dem löffel hier
einführen aber mit dem spritzbeutel kann
ich ein bisschen sauberer arbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die vertiefungen damit
befüllen jetzt wahrscheinlich was mache
ich wenn ich keine überraschung backform
habe dann macht die pflanzkübel schwebe
neben der prozess normalerweise gehört
backen kuchen ganz normal in einem
backblech und die füllung er wird diese
cremige füllung die kommt dann einfach
oben drauf also als belag und anspannung
aber weil ich diese 24 leben hier rein
ein bisschen was habe ich jetzt noch
übrig das werde ich einfach in die
fährten lesen und später mit erste
ansehen
und jetzt kommt der deckel dran und zwar
nehme ich jetzt die seite wo ich vorhin
und bist du was abgucken habe wenn das
alles unter weiter das eigentlich stürzt
auf einen trottel retter und habe jetzt
eine schöne klassen seite oben
das kann ich jetzt mit hilfe ist dort
muss hier drauf setzen
[Musik]
plötzlich fiel um versteckt der kuchen
musik in den kühlschrank für etwa eine
stunde und nach dieser stunde werde ich
dem schoß zu bereiten
und dann kann ich mich schon serviert
werden der kuchen ist abgekühlt und
jetzt werde ich den socket zu bereiten
der kommt nämlich oben drauf und wer ist
auch das besondere an wänden kuchen
wirklich mal die zutaten für den
schokoladen ist brauche ich insgesamt
200 milliliter flüssigkeit ich habe
zuerst bei espresso von 80 milliliter
und den rest will ich mit 120 auf acht
bis neun fordert sogar mit krakau und
rund 100 jahren schokolade
jetzt nehme ich zuerst einmal die beiden
flüssigkeiten wie kommen in den topf und
falls ihr keinem ist also lasst ihn
einfach weg und den 200 millilitern
milch da kommt der puderzucker mit dort
wohl und cacau mit muslimischen ein mal
aufgekocht werden
[Musik]
die mischung das jetzt ganz kurz kochen
das sind wirklich sport und kocht jetzt
kam heraus machen und dann auf die
schokolade einrühren
die sauce ist jetzt gut verrührt die
last abfüll und weise darauf gleich um
fünf und dann kann ich sie kurz vor dem
servieren über die tortenstücke geben
das heißt ich werde den kuchen aus dem
kühlschrank holen und kuchen stücke
schneiden
aber natürlich so dass ich zwischen den
wellen schneide und somit die
überraschung füllung ihnen bleibt oder
suizid die sieht man dann nämlich erst
später wenn der gast und dort derjenige
deswegen ist auch angaben
[Musik]
ist also das fertige tortenstück und ich
muss sagen erste wetter steht und sich
das wasser im mund zusammenläuft stimmt
irgendwas denn es lief super lecker aus
hier habe ich noch die eine portion
mohandes für zwei personen nach hause
kommen die könnte sich auch die erle
übergeben
wenn ihr möchtet ihr könnt aber auch vor
genießen und einfach auch mal einmal die
kompetenz und wurde jetzt im kühlschrank
fenster also schon steht fest geworden
und möchte ich ganz toll nach wandel und
ich würde sagen weil morath nicht zeit
zum probieren wir alle probieren ganz
gemeinschaftlich und ich muss auch dazu
sagen dass ich eine riesengroße menge
das heißt falls ihr die überraschungs
backform nicht habt und nicht eben
diesen doppeldecker backen wollte macht
einfach nur die einfache menge anzeigt
und dann reicht die creme und ich hoffen
so auf jeden fall auch aus damals 24
kuchenstücke und die sind wirklich sehr
gut und sehr lässig ok auf 3 1
[Musik]
elektra
lassen
beispiel h da ist die ganze und vor
allem finde ich schmeckt man dem
espresso raus das ist natürlich der
rallye spezialeffekt oder der cdu-spitze
als bonus denn normalerweise kommen da
kein extra so mitreißt aber ich finde
dass ich noch mal so ein
geschmacksträger und passt wirklich
super auch bei den erdbeeren und für
seine mohammed ich bin als er dieses
rezept also auch nach machen wollt geht
auf meinem blog auf realismus blog.de
schaut euch an und macht auf jeden fall
nach ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
dabei wir werden es wahrscheinlich etwas
passiert genießen und euch natürlich
noch einen wundervollen tag bis zum
nächsten mal sehen
[Musik]
apa